gentlemen welcome to fight
first rule of Fight Club is you do not
talk about by car
the beginning of the conversation about
final support but think I may have
missed a birthday a birthday Nick well
we'll be checking in on that hockey
everything all right is that supposed to
be funny we're ranking girls what do you
think you are who's that I found it
Napster just because you can't prove it
doesn't mean it's not true
goodsoon
you're looking for me Who am I speaking
with the zodiac speaking
I did not kill my wife rather not talk
about for what it's worth it's never too
late boy in my case too early to be
whoever you want to be
there's no time limit stop whatever you
want you can change or stay the same
I've no rules to this thing
we can make the best of the voice time I
hope you make the best time
I hope you see things as Tavia oh yeah
these things you never felt before
I hope you meet people with a different
point of view I hope you live life you
proud if you find that you're not I hope
you have the strength to start all over
again